quelles sont les avancées du quinquennat
d' emmanuel macron en matière d'économie
la première avancée c'est la baisse
massive des impôts qui efface 10 ans
d'augmentation de la pression fiscale
dans notre pays pour les français
d'abord avec la suppression de la taxe
d'habitation avec la baisse de l'impôt
sur le revenu avec la baisse des
cotisations qui pèsent sur le travail et
puis avec la création du prélèvement
forfaitaire unique pour les entreprises
également avec la baisse de l'impôt sur
les sociétés et la baisse très forte des
impôts de production avec tout cela
grâce à emmanuel macron nous revenons à
la situation d'avant 2010 avant que les
impôts ne recommence à augmenter la
deuxième avancée c'est la revalorisation
du travail avec les exonérations sur les
heures supplémentaires avec la prima
kron et puis plus récemment avec la
réforme de l'assurance chômage qui vont
garantir que le travail paye plus que
l'inactivité et puis avec la réforme de
la formation professionnelle et de
l'apprentissage
qu'aucun des prédécesseurs emmanuel
macron n'avait eu le courage
d'entreprendre avant lui la troisième
avancée c'est la construction d'un
modèle de croissance plus durable avec
l'index pour l'égalité entre les femmes
et les hommes et la parité dans les
comités de direction qui vont donner aux
femmes une place pleine et entière dans
notre économie et dans nos entreprises
avec le développement de l'actionnariat
salarié de l'intéressement de la
participation qui sont autant de levier
pour mieux partager les fruits de la
croissance et puis avec la loi pacte qui
a créé les entreprises à mission et qui
a créé la raison d'être parce que nous
croyons que les entreprises ont un rôle
citoyen à jouer avec toutes ces avancées
il y a également la réponse
extraordinaire à la crise le quoi qu'il
en coûte avec les mesures de soutien qui
ont sauvé des millions d'emplois avec le
plan de relance qui chaque jour se
déploie dans nos territoires pour
accélérer la transition écologique et la
transition numérique de nos entreprises
et puis avec france 2030 qui engagent
notre pays sur une trajectoire d'avenir